let me get into that spinal position oh
my God that 46 years oh my God I was
saving that one for you oh my
God oh my
God oh my he
came he
came he finished he finished let's run
that back dude let me get into that
spinal position oh my
God
let me get into that spinal position oh
my God oh my
God oh my
[Laughter]
God when she let you go raw for the
first time that spinal position oh my
god when your when your wife sleeps with
a college guy get into that spinal
position oh my
God
that look at his
face dude he's seeing that shroom couple
right
now he ate an
onion oh my God he's like
yeah oh my God oh my man I just wish the
guy wasn't talking in the beginning I
just want let me get into that spinal
position oh my God all I want that's all
I want oh my God that can't be good for
you right call me
paralyzed
[Laughter]
yeah nice yeah
thanks you you ever seen that one where
he's like dress up in the bright yellow
track suit and he's like call me a
tennis ball oh no ah it's good oh I
didn't realiz like phrase call me
something I was trying to figure it out
oh it's like yeah it's like a meme
because it's like there's a funny tweet
about it it was like he just he'll just
give his wife his phone and be like film
me doing this and he'll do this annoying
ass voice yeah that you can tell she
just [__] hates you think she loves
him
still I would hope so I feel she loes
him yeah that's one new quote alert call
me a tennis ball let's play tennis toad
head toad head you never seen listen
he's in like the forest green one he's
like call me asparagus I've seen that
one I've seen that one yeah seen that
one so that's his one of his
things oh call me
paralyzed man I I wish I could see her
face on the other side of that she's
just
yeah call me tennis ball tennis
ball okay tennis
ball come on honey call me tennis ball
hey tennis ball hey tennis ball dang
yeah that's got to be a that's got to be
a a a unique experience that being your
husband yeah going to family parties and
stuff yeah Uncle hey what's up kid call
me tennis ball it's not Uncle it's not
Uncle Ked anymore it's Uncle tennis ball
it's Uncle tennis
ball and he's elbowing her he right
honeyy she's like yeah yeah it is yeah
Uncle tennis ballis yep tennis
ball
Uncle tennis ball damn
it in-laws khed how you doing oh it's
tennis ball now actually call me tennis
ball come on man I'm not sorry I'm sorry
Mom
Dad hey tennis you want a you want you
want mashed potatoes with your chicken
it's DJ tennis ball damn it that should
that should have been your name man DJ
tennis ball yeah yeah so he been running
yeah but you ain't been lifting no back
to lifting yeah I want to get back into
it I want to start doing like just
pull-ups push-ups cuz it's like the
easiest way in yeah you know could do
some right now
what yeah should we just bang on some
Archer push-ups what are Archer
push-ups you're going to want to get
your hands in a super position okay kind
of spread out and you're just going to
kind of reach back oh
nice and then you can yeah see that's
some Cal Aesthetics right there
I can't do one hand cut here I'm going
to do a one-handed push-up do on the
break yeah know he's going to doing the
bonus you got to you got to come see the
bonus if you want to see him do bonus if
you want to see the one-handed push-up
yeah this what you call one-handed
push-up yeah yeah we got it all right
all right call me Nick
Walker yeah we got it
yeah we that that was a great great view
dude great taint shot there
yeah I already uh I already gave uh
everyone a bunch of ammo last week what
when I just bent over and grabbed my
[__] busy wait when was that uh I
forgot I was like average csgo player
and I stood up and put my ass through
the yeah you
know now we got to do another one of
these I'm having fun man I'm having fun
too I realize my head hurts after we
record cuz we're always giggling me too
I'm always spent I'm spent right now
always and uh Kelsey's like what's wrong
and I'm like I just been giggling so
much today we giggled a lot yeah it's
got to be giggle with me it's got to be
irritating for our partners I'm giggled
out okay yeah let me re reg giggle let
me rejuvenate my Giggles yeah what yeah
you got to actually giggle tonight yeah
I have to giggle tonight yeah cuz that
you have no excuse not to yeah why are
you tired sorry I was just giggling with
my boy for like two
hours just excessive
giggling bro chill I'm giggling chill
just giggling bro chill I'm just
giggling bro chill out i' I giggled too
much today have you seen this guy
[__] uh Joshua Block B Bon on Tik Tok
yeah B Bon yeah B bony you seen that
[__] by the way you wait you've seen the
ones where he oh I think we watched one
of these so yeah he was the one that did
the slot scraper but there's another one
where he goes up to some guy and he's
like ha man you haven't hit [__] yet
have you seen that one no it's so
[__] fun is he the one that ask for
directions uh no he he basically
pretends it's the Balon guy Johnny ham
yeah Johnny hamek he he goes up to one
guy and he's like man I've been watching
you for for a while dude you haven't hit
[__] yet and the dude like just doesn't
respond the guy just like doesn't turn
around so he's like all right man good
luck and he walks away and he just walks
literally like 10 slot machines down to
a second guy and he does the exact same
thing and the dude looks at me he's like
what and he's like hey what's up it's
Johnny man I haven't seen you in so long
man the guy's like oh yeah wait I don't
know
you he's like yeah you do I uh you know
I had that uh slots Addiction Counseling
class last year and you were there God
he's like no that was not me and he's
like yeah it was that was you same guy
about 4 foot one same wiry [__] on his
face just digging him out digging him in
and the guy and it's so funny cuz the
guy's like he keeps going no that's not
me that's not me I don't have a problem
and the guy's like all right man you
know that's what a lot of them say
though you know so if you're just saying
this like I see you and the guy's like
no it's not me he's like you sure cuz I
look after my clients oh my God bro I
thought you going to say eventually he
gave in and he was like don't tell my
wife just fell apart as he don't tell
her I'm here just start weeping yeah I'm
trying to quit I'm trying to
quit